a section of Canada's medical assistance
and dying law that excludes people whose
sole condition is mental illness was set
to expire this March now Health Minister
Mark Hollands says the government agrees
with a new report that warned Canada is
not ready we agree with the conclusion
uh that the committee has come to uh
that the system is at this time not
ready uh and more time uh is required
the federal government has been facing a
March 17th deadline over the issue that
stems from a 2021 expansion of made that
excluded mental illness from eligibility
but only for 2 years Ottawa had already
pressed pause last year after Canada's
top psychiatrist voice concerns the
government also brought back a
parliamentary committee to study if
medical professionals were ready for the
expansion set for this year but on
Monday a joint parliamentary committee
report said fundamental issues around
the expansion have not been resolved the
conservatives also released a dissenting
report saying it would be Reckless and
dangerous for the scheduled change to
occur in March and want the rules to
abandon the expansion altogether the
health Minister says a response to the
report will be tabled in the House of
Commons delaying expansion of the
criteria but that needs to be passed
before March 17th Sean preville Global
News